Transcription: Mandy Vincent
Relecteur: eric vautier
Être sur scène, c’est quand
même assez inconfortable, non ?
Je me demande souvent pourquoi je fais ça,
de parler devant les gens.
Quand j’étais plus jeune,
j’avais vraiment de la difficulté,
même juste à commander dans un restaurant
parce que j’étais vraiment gênée.
Je demandais à mes amis
de le faire à ma place.
Aujourd’hui, j’ai envie de
vous faire apprécier l’inconfort
parce que je suis certaine qu’il y a
une puissance qu’on peut tous trouver.
Est-ce que ça peut être
bénéfique pour notre santé ?
Est-ce que ça peut nous aider
à entreprendre et aller de l’avant ?
Mon nom, c’est Caroline Côté,
je suis une réalisatrice
de documentaires d’aventure.
Faire des expéditions de
longue distance en milieu froid,
c’est ma passion et mon travail.
Je suis au Svalbard,
dans l’obscurité totale
de l’hiver arctique,
juste en-dessous du pôle Nord.
J’embarque dans la plus
grande expédition de ma vie.
Là-bas,
ça va être la première traversée
hivernale en autonomie complète.
Les conditions : il fait -40°C
et je vais devoir faire environ
1000 kilomètres de distance.
Je suis accompagnée pour les faire
de l’explorateur polaire Vincent Colliard.
Au départ, je ne vois rien dans la nuit
parce que là-bas ça dure
presque toute la journée,
à cette période de l’année.
Mes skis s’enfoncent dans la neige.
Ensuite, mon traîneau est tellement
lourd qu’il me tire vers l’arrière
malgré le fait que j’ai amené
seulement le strict minimum.
J’ai même amené que deux paires
de chaussettes avec moi
dans mon traîneau pour deux mois.
C’est 125 kilos que
je dois traîner chaque jour.
Au Svalbard, c’est plus
d’ours que d’hommes.
Pendant la période de préparation, je me
familiarise avec le maniement des armes
juste pour être prête au cas
où il y aurait une rencontre.
Est-ce que l’humain est fait pour vivre
dans des situations aussi inconfortables ?
C’est la question que
je me pose à ce moment-là.
Un soir, la tempête fait rage,
je suis ensevelie par
une montagne de neige.
Je me demande combien
de temps la tente va résister.
Je dois pelleter et pelleter encore,
malgré la tempête.
Cette nuit-là,
j’ai dormi juste 50 minutes.
Au matin, quand je me lève,
je me regarde dans le miroir de
la boussole que j’ai apportée avec moi.
Je ne reconnais pas mon visage,
il a pris des années en quelques jours.
Je crois que c’est un
des symptômes du froid.
J’ai les larmes aux yeux quand vient
le temps d’enfiler mes bottes de ski
qui sont complètement gelées.
Est-ce que je m’étais lancé
un trop grand défi ?
Après un mois,
le manque de calories
commence à se faire sentir.
La nuit, je me réveille en tremblant
par manque de nourriture.
Là, je commence à sentir
ma respiration qui s’accélère.
Je panique et je me sens
vraiment inconfortable.
« OK, ça ne va vraiment pas. »
C’est ce que je me dis à cet instant-là.
C’est par la suite que
je réussis à comprendre
quels sont les bienfaits de se retrouver
en situation d’inconfort en plein air.
Dans une expédition
au Svalbard ou à Montréal,
dans le monde de l’entrepreneuriat,
ça peut être vraiment inconfortable.
Je pense que vous en savez quelque chose.
Il y a une grande part d’inconnu dans
le fait de tracer son propre chemin,
de dépasser sa zone de confort.
Il peut y avoir de l’insécurité,
du risque, de l’incertitude,
et même parfois de la douleur.
Mais pourquoi d’abord
on va se challenger ?
Et pourquoi on va le faire
dans la nature ?
C’est quoi les forces cachées
de vivre l’inconfort ?
Mais tout d’abord,
je crois que de vivre l’adversité,
ça nous permet d’avoir
à l’intérieur de notre corps
quelque chose de très naturel,
une drogue naturelle
qui s’appelle le bien-être.
Pendant la période de Covid,
on a réalisé que la nature aidait
à l’équilibre d’un corps
et d’un esprit sain.
Ça apportait des bénéfices
de se retrouver en plein air.
En devenant résidente en Norvège,
j’ai trouvé quelques réflexions
vraiment intéressantes.
Les Norvégiens ont un mode de vie
scandinave qui s’appelle « Friluftsliv ».
Je ne sais pas s’il y en a ici
qui parlent norvégien.
J'essaie d'apprendre la langue.
« Frilufts », ça veut dire plein air
et « Liv » ça veut dire vie,
donc « vivre en plein air ».
Vivre en plein air,
c’est un terme qui implique d’accepter
ce que la nature nous offre,
tous les aléas de la nature,
d’apprécier de vivre en plein air.
À l’époque des chasseurs-cueilleurs,
l’inconfort prenait
une grande place  dans leur vie.
À l’époque de la révolution industrielle,
on s’est sédentarisé et on a perdu
la connexion avec la nature.
Avec l’urbanisation,
la nature a été perçue
comme un milieu hostile.
Puis, c’est là qu’on a
commencé graduellement
à se dire qu’on devait
vivre plus à l’intérieur.
Ensuite, avec l’arrivée
des technologies modernes
dans le mode de vie norvégien,
le sentiment de calme, d’équilibre
semblait manquer à leurs vies.
Le mouvement de retour à la nature
est arrivé dans les années 1990.
C’est là qu’est apparu
le terme « Friluftsliv ».
Mais quel est l’impact
de se retrouver en plein air
sur notre cerveau humain ?
C’est là que j’ai essayé de faire
le lien avec nos neurotransmetteurs.
Aujourd’hui, on est sous
l’emprise de la dopamine.
Ce n’est pas une mauvaise hormone
mais ce qu’il faut savoir,
c’est que c’est généré
par une abondance
de plaisir immédiat et rapide,
comme par exemple, l’alcool, le café,
même les réseaux sociaux ou le sucre.
Ce sont des pics de plaisir spontanés
et vraiment rapides.
Complètement de l’autre côté,
on a la sérotonine.
La sérotonine, sur le long terme,
met notre cerveau dans
une espèce de bain de bien-être.
Il y a des études à l’université
de Californie à San Francisco
qui démontrent qu’une hausse
du niveau de dopamine entraîne
des baisses significatives de
la sérotonine dans notre corps,
ce qui veut dire
une diminution du bien-être.
Et il y a d’autres recherches
qui m’intéressent vraiment,
qui prouvent que faire une expédition
ou vivre une aventure,
un contexte en plein air,
ça amène une levée significative
du taux de sérotonine dans notre corps.
C’est là que j’ai compris la raison pour
laquelle je voulais faire des aventures
et en faire mon travail.
Vivre l’inconfort, ça nous amène
à être plus adaptable
dans notre quotidien.
Je reviens tout juste
d’une expédition en Arctique.
Là-bas, j’en ai appris beaucoup.
J’avais vécu les situations
les plus inconfortables pour moi,
des crevasses en Antarctique,
être dans des avalanches
dans les Rocheuses,
ou encore submergée par les vagues
dans une expédition de canot
sur la rivière Yukon sur 3200 kilomètres.
Mais c’est là-bas, tout récemment,
que mon ego en a vraiment pris un coup.
Je vous explique.
Grise Fiord est le village le plus
au nord du continent américain.
Déplacés par le gouvernement canadien,
les habitants là-bas avaient vécu
des situations vraiment plus
éprouvantes que les miennes.
J’ai eu la chance d’aller
sur le terrain et de découvrir
les facultés d’adaptation des Inuits.
J’ai eu la chance de parler
avec eux d’adaptabilité.
Un jour, il y a mon ami inuit qui me dit :
« Caro, est-ce que tu viens chasser ? »
Je suis un peu sous
le choc parce qu’en ville,
je m’alimente à base de plantes.
Donc, je ne sais pas trop comment réagir
mais j’apprends que ça peut aider
à nourrir une partie de la communauté
pendant quelques jours.
Alors, j’accepte de le suivre.
J’ai mes bottes au pied,
ma caméra en main.
On part.
Il fait - 33°C à l’extérieur,
chose qui est normale là-bas.
Moi, je ne trouve pas ça normal.
Sur le terrain, je commence
à prendre des vidéos
malgré les températures vraiment froides.
Sur ma caméra, il y a un fil
qui se brise à cause du froid,
et l’énergie des batteries
descend rapidement
Mais malgré tout, malgré mon inconfort,
j’essaie de continuer
à le suivre dans cette chasse.
Je demande à mon ami
comment on fait pour trouver
les trous de respiration
des phoques sur le terrain.
Avec un pic à glace, il va sonder la neige
et on va pouvoir les trouver.
Ensuite, il faut rester vingt minutes,
sans bouger,
sans faire un bruit
pour attendre les phoques.
Vingt minutes à méditer
dans mon appartement,
j’ai déjà du mal à le faire.
Je trouve ça assez difficile.
Mais quand on est sur un fjord gelé
avec un vent violent devant
et -30°C, c’est plus compliqué.
Finalement, on n’a pas attrapé
de phoques ce jour-là.
Mais ce que ça m’a appris,
c’est qu’on peut agrandir
notre zone de confort,
on peut s’adapter.
Quand on n’a pas le choix,
quand on doit se nourrir, se loger
ou même être en sécurité,
on ne se pose pas de questions,
on trouve des solutions,
et on s’adapte.
C'est ce que j'ai retenu.
Ensuite, je pense
que de vivre l’inconfort,
ça peut nous amener à être plus résilient.
Le récit d’expédition d’Ernest Shackleton
a changé ma vie.
En 1914, il était avec son équipe
sur le voilier l'Endurance.
Ils ont levé les voiles
vers l'Antarctique.
Ils sont restés pris dans
les glaces pendant deux ans.
Là-bas, il fait -60°C en hiver.
Il n’y avait pas de Gore-Tex, c’est sûr,
mais je veux dire c’est incroyable.
J’y suis allé en été et j’étais gelée.
Malgré les conditions atroces
et le manque de nourriture,
ils sont restés vivants
grâce à Shackleton.
Ils sont tous revenus sains et saufs
et je pense que cette histoire a changé
ma perspective du mot résilience.
J’ai un souvenir vraiment précis
en tête que j’aimerais vous raconter.
Je m'en allais dans la même région
de l'Antarctique avec une équipe.
C’était ma première grande expédition.
Quelques semaines avant le départ,
j’ai eu une réponse positive des autres
membres de l’équipe pour me joindre à eux.
Par contre, le chef de l'équipe
a donné son refus.
Mon CV n’avait pas réussi
à le convaincre à l’époque.
Sur le coup, les larmes coulent.
Je suis gênée.
Je n’arrive pas à le croire.
Et ensuite, ce refus m’a ouvert les yeux.
J’ai réussi dans les semaines suivantes
à acquérir l’expérience qu’il me fallait.
J'ai redoublé d'efforts.
C'est là que j'ai le plus appris.
Finalement, on est allé en Antarctique,
unis plus que jamais
pour affronter l’inconnu
dans les conditions
les plus froides de la planète.
Winston Churchill nous a dit un jour
que le succès, c’est passé
d’un échec à un autre
en restant enthousiaste.
Je crois que vivre dans
l’inconfort nous amène à grandir.
Dans les fjords de Norvège
où j’habite maintenant,
j’ai été inspirée par les crustacés qui se
trouvent dans les fjords d’eau froide
que j’explore en kayak là-bas.
Le homard a une carapace
dure et élastique.
Pour grandir, il a besoin de la perdre.
Pendant la mue, il absorbe beaucoup d’eau,
ce qui lui fait perdre
son ancienne coquille,
ce qui lui permet d’en avoir une nouvelle.
Ça s’appelle l’exuvie.
Moi, j’ai vraiment été
inspirée par le homard.
Je pense que j’ai besoin, comme lui,
de me sentir inconfortable
pour grandir, pour évoluer.
Ces expériences dans les milieux polaires
m’ont fait comprendre qu’on ne
contrôle pas toujours la situation.
Je dois m'adapter.
Mais je pense que c’est en
acceptant les moments difficiles,
et en prenant le temps dans l’effort
que je vais y arriver.
Ce qui me motive à faire mon travail,
c’est de montrer qu’il est
possible de rêver grand,
de repousser nos limites, de se dépasser
pour atteindre les buts qu’on s’est fixés.
Aujourd’hui, je suis persuadée
que de vivre l’inconfort,
c’est bénéfique quand on arrive
à l’apprivoiser à son avantage,
quand on en connaît les bienfaits.
Aujourd’hui, je me tiens devant vous
en étant libre, heureuse,
et confiante, confortable.
C’est pourquoi j’aimerai vous amener,
pas nécessairement à vivre l’inconfort,
mais j’aimerais vous en faire
reconnaître toute la puissance.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)